صهيب لماذا تعد الليله الماضيه منعطفا في
حرب غزه تعد الليله الماضيه منعطفا في حرب
غزه بسبب لاكثر من سبب السبب الاول تكثيف
الغارات الاسرائيليه بطريقه غير مسبوقه في
المناطق الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه
والشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه اي ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي رسم حذوه فرس في محيط
مدينه غزه من الجهه الغربيه والجهه
الشماليه والجهه الشرقيه بقصف عنيف للغايه
ايضا كان هناك حديث من كتاب القسام على
توغل لاو محاوله توغ الاسرائيليه في منطقه
بيت حنون في اقصى الشمال الشرقي من مدينه
غزه عند الزاويه بين قطاع غزه ومدينه
ديروت الاسرائيليه المخلاه بطبيعه الحال
وهناك ايضا كان هناك محاوله تسلل اخرى في
منطقه البريج في شرق قطاع غزه في المنطقه
الوسطى هاتان المحاولتين قالت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بانها تصدت لهما وافشل تهما
وان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يستطع الدخول
الى داخل حدود قطاع غزه ولكننا نتحدث عن
حوالي عمق كيلو متر على محيط قطاع غزه في
السياج الحدودي او المنطقه الفاصله بين
المناطق الماهوله في قطاع غزه ومناطق داخل
الخط الاخضر هذا العمق كيلومتر اذا لم
يستطع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الدخول
والتمركز في عمق كيلو متر على الاقل فانه
لا يعتبر انه تقدم بالفعل في قطاع غزه
وتوغل بريا وانه استطاع التمركز كتابه
قسام تقول انها تنتظر العمليه البريه التي
اعلن عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي بفارغ الصبر
رغم انه التهديدات الاسرائيليه تقول بانه
لابد من العمليه البريه ولا بد من دفع
الثمن في هذه العمليه البريه لانه لا يمكن
الانتصار على حماس كما تقول اسرائيل الا
بهذه العمليه البريه بالتالي يكثف
الاحتلال من غاراته في محاولات للدخول
البري تكثيف الغارات يؤدي الى سقوط عدد
كبير من الشهداء
والمصابين يوم امس الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قطع كل خدمات الاتصالات والانترنت عن قطاع
غزه وبطبيعه الحال الكهرباء والماء مقطوعه
عن القطاع وبالتالي الاوضاع سانيه ماساويه
للغايه الضغط العسكري هائل للغايه لا يمكن
الحديث الان عن عدد دقيق للشهداء فنحن
نتحدث عن حوالي اكثر من 7000 اسير الليله
الماضيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم احصاء عدد
الا عدد الشهداء في قطاع غزه لان
الاتصالات مقطوعه والطرق التحرك يبدو صعب
للغايه في التحرك بين المناطق التي يقصف
الاحتلال والمستشفيات وبالتالي نحن نتحدث
عن ليله كانت صعبه للغايه ولكن المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تقول بانها تصدت لمحاولات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التوغل وانها مستعده
لاي توغل بري قادم من الاحتلال نحو قطاع
غزه